[Música]
[Aplausos]
por que você escolheu essa roupa para
vir aqui hoje que sensações ela te passa
que sente assim quando você usa ela que
você acha que ela transmite as pessoas
está confortável sexy moderno talvez
toda a roupa que a gente usa passa
alguma mensagem e até algumas pessoas
até então de jeans e camiseta
toda de preto pode pensar não fazendo
mensagem alguma mas sem dúvida as nossas
escolhas
o nosso estilo falam muito mais sobre a
gente do que a gente imagina
e nesse sentido encontrar o estilo certo
pode ser transformador responder essas
perguntas sempre uma grande motivação
para mim desde a infância ouvindo
barulho da máquina de costura da minha
vó vendo aquelas mulheres nas novelas
assim super montadas ou até desenhando
as minhas próprias coleções com bonecas
de papel nessa época aí eu já pensava já
queria já tinha esse sonho de trabalhar
com moda
apesar de não saber muito bem com que
esse sonho e só foi crescendo ao longo
do tempo e no início da idade adulta fez
com que eu saísse de lá da minha cidade
natal bellei pra são paulo pra em busca
de estudar moda e conhecer pessoas da
indústria tentar alguma coisa nessa área
muita gente sai de cidades pequenas para
são paulo
aquele sonho quero fazer acontecer e não
demora muito para ter um choque de
realidade com a cidade e comigo
adoraria dizer que foi diferente mas não
foi
cheguei lá e prá tentar fazer o som de
acontecer
tive uma série de decepções
tive esse choque de realidade e um dos
motivos assim um dos grandes motivos é
que eu tinha ido estudar moda conhecer
os grandes eventos e na minha cabeça era
tudo muito idealizado achava que era
tudo lindo maravilhoso tudo é como as
revistas e chegando lá não foi bem assim
e aí isso fez com que o engavetasse esse
sonho por uns anos e fosse fazer outras
coisas
passaram se vários anos mesmo trabalhei
várias áreas diferentes
até que eu fui receber uma proposta para
ser apresentadora de tv
trabalhei na televisão por seis anos e
se a apresentadora de tv e eu sei que é
um sonho de muita gente muita gente a
assistir televisão com a nossa que legal
só que não era o meu sonho foi uma coisa
que aconteceu e diariamente
podia ter o melhor dos cenários mas eu
tinha algum cômodo assim aqui alguma
coisa não estava resolvida
rolava até que ela se intrometeu
impostor sabe de gente não queria que
eles vão descobrir que eu não sou
apresentadora de tv coisa nenhuma alguém
vai chegar aqui me levar embora
mas chegar esse momento e demorou um
tempão pra entender que todo esse
sentimento esse incômodo era causada
pelo sonho que eu tinha vetado anos
antes
e aí pensando nisso depois de muito
muita reflexão decidi que era hora de
fazer alguma coisa e comecei a uma série
de transformações pessoais nesse sentido
inclusive transformei meu próprio visual
meu próprio estilo mudou e decidi que
precisava voltar a estudar moda
comecei a fazer vários cursos e foi
nessa que eu encontrei a consultoria de
estilo
encontrei um curso encontra a profissão
realmente as coisas começaram a fazer
sentido para mim comecei a entender o
que eu queria que caminho eu queria
seguir a moda e eu encontrei a diferença
prática entre moda e estilo
na minha concepção é que moda tem muito
mais a ver com o sistema um ciclo com o
fato de que uma coisa precisa cair para
que outra entrou em voga e para algumas
pessoas moda pode até ser um conceito
opressor
agora o estilo tem muito mais a ver com
alto conhecimento tem muito mais a ver
com quem você é de que forma você
expressa isso para o mundo e como
consultora de estilo do trabalho muito
menos com construção de imagem de moda e
muito mais com construção de estilo de
vida às pessoas que eu atendo são
pessoas de verdade com os sonhos anseios
dramas pessoais
felicidades são mulheres e sempre
separadas são homens em busca de
desenvolvimento pessoal
mães que tiveram seus filhos esqueceram
delas mesmas e agora estão em busca
dessa personalidade
todas essas pessoas são únicas
o universo em expansão mas todas elas
têm uma coisa em comum elas passam ou
passaram assim como eu por uma
transformação pessoal que motivou essa
vontade de mostrar personalidade delas
por meio do estilo não é fácil né
logo uma longa jornada para que isso
aconteça uma história que eu gosto de
contar é de uma pessoa que me procurou
que tinha recente tratado de um câncer
ela tinha perdido muito peso tinha
passado por um processo de quimioterapia
por muita medicação e com certeza ela
não era mais a mesma pessoa
ela tinha sido um dia e falando assim
vocês devem pensar em uma pessoa
coitada da batida não é triste sim
ganhou porque era foi uma das pessoas
mais felizes que eu tive a oportunidade
de atender na minha profissão estava
feliz com a vida o simples fato de tali
está viva e querendo reconstruir tudo
então nós fizemos vários foram muitas
conversas muita reflexão também fizemos
análises coloração pessoal que é pq
cores ficam melhor em cada tipo físico
vamos observar que roupas que ela tinha
no armário
aliás sobre análises coloração é uma
pessoa muito colorida ela queria mostrar
essas cores para o mundo estava com nove
desde diz
e olhando as roupas dela no guarda roupa
a gente teve certeza de que ela não se
enxergava mais ali e depois numa outra
parte da consultoria que aí até as lojas
e provar roupas de um estilo que a gente
identificou como sendo mais próximo ao
dela uma das grandes alegrias que eu
tive assim de pensar que tudo realmente
estava fazendo sentido
depois de ver o sorriso no rosto dela
quando ela se olhou no espelho e
finalmente reconheceu
era isso outra história de uma jovem
executiva que me procurou porque ela
tinha sido promovida para chefiar uma
equipe só de homens mais velhos do que
ela e ela é uma mulher de aparência doce
e delicada
queria passar uma imagem visual mais
incisiva se mostrar como líder e
principalmente ser respeitada pela
equipe dela e fizemos também a
consultoria
conversamos bastante e depois de todo o
processo
ela me deu um retorno que me deixou
pensando
ela me disse que passará a usar salto
alto para ir ao trabalho tinha mudado a
vida dela pra melhor
porque ela levantava ela estava mais
alta que aqueles homens ela se sentir
poderosa e isso influenciou várias
outras mudanças na vida dela porque fez
com que ela se sentisse mais confiante
em decisões de trabalho e várias outras
coisas e o porquê isso me deixou
pensando porque eu comecei a pensar que
isso que eu falei pra vocês agora de que
encontrar o estilo certo é transformador
porque também mostra quem a gente é que
a nossa personalidade é legal é ótimo
mas também tem umas coisas simples de um
corte de cabelo um salto alto que causa
mudanças internas e fazem com que nosso
interior conhecida com quem a gente quer
ser o que a gente busca então é uma via
de mão dupla
vocês lembram é assim é uma via de mão
dupla porque a gente encontra a
felicidade não lembro que eu falei que
estava infeliz tinha um incômodo
cheguei em são paulo e tinha alguma
coisa errada e eu tive há uns anos eu
tive a oportunidade de também poder a
língua me arrepender disso e enxergar a
moda por uma nova perspectiva porque na
minha cabeça uma diferente diferença
muito clara e tinha uma linha onde eu
não podia ir na moda e eu fui convidada
por uma marca que eu admiro muito e que
desfila na são paulo fashion week para
trabalhar junto com eles há um tempo
atrás e apesar de estar muito feliz na
consultoria de estilo eu vi que ali era
uma oportunidade de participar de uma
criação de moda que não era padronizada
que não estava dentro daquele daquela
coisa que eu imitei sabe e aceitei e
acabamos acabei trabalhando em três
coleções com eles
na primeira eu fiz a parte de stalin que
a composição dos looks dos acessórios
das fotos de campanha cujo principal
resultado foi essa foto
no segundo eu entrei um pouco mais o
início fiz a parte de pesquisa e
desenvolvimento da coleção uma coleção
chamada herança que ela tinha muita
inspiração no samba antigo agora na
terceira eu entrei no início e fui
convidada para ser coordenadora de qom
são que é um trabalho insano muita gente
ver a superfície e acha que é fácil mas
que eu passei várias noites sem dormir
fiquei desesperada achando que a coleção
não ia sair mas todo o esforço valeu a
pena
na hora do desfile quando surgiu essa
imagem na passarela
para quem não conhece essa é a mc carol
ela é uma cantora de funk lado o rio de
janeiro é uma pessoa que está
completamente fora dos padrões da
indústria da moda e consequentemente do
são paulo fashion week é alguém que
raramente talvez nunca é visto num
evento como esse
visando uma passarela e pra mim vela
entrando na passarela sendo coroada
dessa forma depois de todo o trabalho
foi emocionante foi o grande ponto do
desfile e ela apesar de ser uma pessoa
que tem fama de que fala o que quer
dt letras sobre o empoderamento feminino
é muito tímida e teve uma preocupação
muito grande com o que ela existe e como
isso seria recebido pelas pessoas
talvez por nunca ter se visto no
ambiente como esse que foi muito
importante foi incrível ela entender a
importância dela tá ali pisando nessa
passarela sendo quem ela é vindo de onde
ela vem mostrando para outras pessoas
que elas podem estar lá também que é
possível
servindo como inspiração para outras
pessoas e principalmente por ela
entender que a sua auto confiança está
pisando ali é muito mais importante do
que qualquer look e encontrar o nosso
estilo certo é muito não é fácil como eu
falei é uma transição requer muitos
questionamentos muitas idas e vindas e
foi por isso que eu perguntei pra vocês
lá no início que se usou essa roupa hoje
por que você escolheu essa roupa que te
levou a escolher porque tem muita gente
que tem dificuldade de usar
sei lá o chat chapéu
tem gente que usa isso com tanta
facilidade sai de casa e consegue
e por que tem tanta gente que tem
segurança com se vestir no geral
justamente por se vestir que é uma coisa
que a gente tem que fazer todo dia se
vestir que é que nem comer bbc vai preso
se você não se vestir se sair pelado
então meu convite a todo mundo que tem
essa sim seguranças no andar tanto para
o lado e pensar o que aquilo significa
pra você e como mensagem final eu posso
deixar três coisas
a primeira delas é essa é a pergunta o
que é prioridade pra você
aquelas perguntas lá no começo eu quero
está confortável eu quero está moderno
impactante e o que cada uma dessas
coisas significa pra você porque pra mim
tá impactante é uma coisa talvez pra
você seja outra completamente diferente
é pensar nessas respostas com mais
cuidado
e pensar que aquelas coisas de editorial
de revista de certo e errado hoje são
completamente inaceitáveis
então pensa a sua prioridade vale muito
mais que qualquer tendência outra coisa
lembrar que as roupas são um produto mas
são um produto isso não tem nada a ver
com o seu corpo é bonito e feio
não tem nada a ver elas são uma resposta
ao mercado a oferta e demanda a padrões
da indústria da moda mídia
então por exemplo se você não achar uma
calça que fica ideal no seu corpo numa
determinada loja
hoje em dia tem um milhão de opções para
você procurar por aí dá pra você achar
outros lugares isso requer um pouco mais
de investimento do seu tempo eu gosto
muito dessa palavra investimento porque
ela vende vestimenta a palavra
investimento porque antigamente a
nobreza tinha as roupas tão ricas que
elas eram bordadas com fios de ouro e
metais preciosos então
caso de acontecer alguma coisa algum
problema financeiro as pessoas queimavam
as roupas e caíam fios de ouro ela
conseguia se sustentar por mais um tempo
são roupas são 15 o investimento então e
nada mais justo do que você investir seu
tempo no que te faz bem e lembra
não tem nada a ver com o seu corpo
problema não é o seu corpo são as roupas
lembrar também que por mais que você e
seu estilo estejam completamente
desconectados
você pode pensar e estilo não tem estilo
imagina todo mundo tem algum estilo é só
buscar é uma questão dessa investigação
que eu falei antes e pensar que se
existe uma roupa estranha esquisita ali
que você tem vontade de usar porque
tinha um tenta uma vez a pior coisa que
pode acontecer se você tentar usá não
bater em você na rua será talvez eu seja
julgado mas julgamento ele tem muito
mais a ver com a pessoa que julga do que
com você é a melhor coisa que pode
acontecer é você ter um sorrisão ali no
rosto você se sente autêntico especial
único e eu convido todo mundo assistindo
o único também vai se transformar por
meio do estilo porque como já diria
guimarães rosa que a vida quer da gente
é coragem
obrigada
[Aplausos]